when i was 27 years old i left a very
demanding job in management consulting
for a job that was even more demanding
teaching
i went to teach seventh graders math in
the new york city public schools
and like any teacher i made quizzes and
tests i gave out homework assignments
when the work came back i calculated
grades
what struck me
was that iq was not the only difference
between my best and my worst students
some of my strongest performers did not
have stratospheric iq scores
some of my smartest kids
weren't doing so well
and that got me thinking
the kinds of things you need to learn in
seventh grade math sure they're hard
ratios decimals the area of a
parallelogram
but these concepts are not impossible
and i was firmly convinced that every
one of my students could learn the
material
if they worked hard and long enough
after several more years of teaching
i came to the conclusion that what we
need in education is a much better
understanding of students and learning
from a motivational perspective from a
psychological perspective
in education the one thing we know how
to measure best is iq
but what if doing well in school
and in life
depends on much more than your ability
to learn quickly and easily
so i left the classroom
and i went to graduate school to become
a
psychologist i started studying kids and
adults in all kinds of super challenging
settings
and in every study my question was who
is successful here and why
my research team and i went to west
point military academy
we tried to predict which cadets would
stay in military training and which
would drop out
we went to the national spelling bee and
tried to predict which children would
advance farthest in
competition we studied rookie teachers
working in really tough neighborhoods
asking which teachers are still going to
be here in teaching by the end of the
school year
and of those who will be the most
effective at improving learning outcomes
for their students
we partnered with private companies
asking which of these sales people is
going to keep their jobs and who's going
to earn the most money
in all those very different contexts
one characteristic emerged as a
significant predictor of success
and it wasn't social intelligence
it wasn't good looks
physical health
and it wasn't iq
it was grit
grit is passion and perseverance for
very long term goals
grit is having stamina
grit is sticking with your future
day in day out
not just for the week
not just for the month
but for years
and working really hard to make that
future a reality
grit is living life like it's a marathon
not a sprint
a few years ago i started studying grit
in the chicago public schools
i asked thousands of high school juniors
to take great questionnaires and then
waited around more than a year to see
who would graduate
turns out that grittier kids were
significantly more likely to graduate
even when i matched them on every
characteristic i could measure things
like family income
standardized achievement test scores
even how safe kids felt when they were
at school
so it's not just at west point or the
national spelling bee that grit matters
it's also in school
especially for kids at risk for dropping
out
to me the most shocking thing about grit
is how little we know how little science
knows about building it
every day parents and teachers ask me
how do i build grit in kids what do i do
to teach kids a solid work ethic how do
i keep them motivated for the long run
the honest answer is
i don't know
what i do know is that talent doesn't
make you gritty
our data show very clearly
that there are many talented individuals
who simply do not follow through on
their commitments
in fact in our data grit is usually
unrelated
or even inversely related to measures of
talent
so far the best idea i've heard about
building grit in kids
is something called growth mindset
this is an idea developed at stanford
university by carol dweck
and it is the belief
that the ability to learn is not fixed
that it can change with your effort
dr dweck has shown that when kids read
and learn about the brain
and how it changes and grows in response
to challenge they're much more likely to
persevere when they fail
because
they don't believe that failure is a
permanent condition
so growth mindset is a great idea for
building grit
but we need more
and that's where i'm going to end my
remarks because that's where we are
that's the work that stands before us we
need to take our best ideas our
strongest intuitions and we need to test
them
we need to measure whether we've been
successful and we have to be willing to
fail to be wrong
to start over again with lessons learned
in other words we need to be gritty
about getting our kids grittier
thank you
you